after simple net I'm a postdoc working
in pathogen genomics at the Wellcome
Trust Sanger Institute in Cambridge my
work involves looking at bacteria in
particular ones that are problem in
hospitals because they're resistant to
so many antibiotics the doctors commonly
used I'm using a combination of lab work
DNA sequencing and computational work to
understand how bacteria become resistant
to antibiotics I want to understand if
resistance is something they acquire or
if it's just naturally there within them
while half of my time is more
informatics based the other half is
spent in the lab in the lab I grow up
bacteria on agar plates and then see how
they respond to different antibiotics
while some bugs will be killed by the
antibiotics others will be resistant and
these are the ones that I'm interested
in
I like the hands-on element of working
in the lab setting up the experiments
and then coming back the next day and
discovering the results when I find the
bugs that are resistant to antibiotics I
I salute their DNA I then get this DNA
sequence back on my computer I then
compare this DNA sequence to a database
of genes known to be involved in
antibiotic resistance I can then see if
any of these resistance genes are in my
samples more and more enjoying the
computational side of my research
because it enables me to really pinpoint
the mechanisms of antibiotic resistance
I always enjoyed science at school but
really got fascinated about drug
resistance when I was doing my degree
during my degree I spent a year in
industry looking at drug resistance in
HIV understanding how one mutation can
cause resistance to a whole class of
antivirals was really intriguing to me
I've studied the mechanisms of drug
resistance in bacteria
ever since first for my PhD and now here
at the Sanger Institute I really enjoy
working in research I get to collaborate
lots of very accomplished scientists and
they challenged me every day to me
that's how you really grow as a
scientist drug resistance is fascinating
to me I just want to find out more about
how it develops and how we might have a
comment I love what I do